horace cooper is the co-chairman of
project 21 he joins us tonight horse
thanks so much for coming on so the
concern is not that there's a crazy
prosecutor out there
we've honestly seen that before they're
crazy people out there but if you get
enough people
like rachel rollins all of a sudden
nobody believes in your justice system
anymore and i think that is worth
worrying about
oh i think it's definitely something
worth worrying about and i don't think
it's an accident
black women make up about seven percent
of the population of the united states
how is it that we managed to pick one of
the most unhinged persons that we could
find for this particular position what
we're saying is
the people that actually hate our
criminal justice system the people that
hate americans by the way it's the
victims that these positions are
supposed to be the supporters of it is
not the attackers it is the victims
if she's worried about the cost of quote
housing these people
why doesn't she support stronger
stricter more severe punishments our
framers
understood that you are supposed to hold
criminal behavior accountable
her vision
is the exact opposite of that and what
it's going to do is open
it up so that people start taking
justice for themselves that isn't
civilization that's not progress that's
heading in the exact opposite direction
i think that's such a wise such an
insightful thing to say that is
the end stage of this when you see
people who have no choice but to
administer their own justice and at that
point
is that really a civilized society no of
course not it's it's back to the stone
age at that point
we absolutely have a person that wants
to say
she's a first
she's a first all right unhinged having
to be
brokered having the vice president
brought in to cast the tie-breaking vote
this president it's remarkable he picks
kamala harris incompetent he picks this
person unfit unsuited for this position
what is going on and we should be paying
attention because it's pretty serious i
i think it is serious especially when it
infects the justice system i think it's
really worth paying attention to horse
cooper great to see you tonight thank
you hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else